one thing that a lot of people are
afraid of giving away is stuff that
actually cost them money but I can
assure you that if it actually costs you
money it usually will be valued at a
significantly higher percentage to the
marketplace so sure you can have a free
pdf sure you can have a digital video
series whatever it is but normally
unless it's exceptional people aren't
going to value that cuz that's what a
lot of people do sometimes giving away
actual free work that you will incur
cost on a lot more people will take you
up on and if you do the math you will
ultimately make more money and this what
I'm talking about is the difference
between small business owners and big
business owners they can encourage
calculated cost of front for a much
bigger backend it's really just the
embodiment of long-term thinking versus
short-term